now the government is announcing a new
investment boost for the NHS mental
health services in Newcastle Liverpool
and Gateshead are all set to be expanded
as a result the health secretary Matt
Hancock says it's about giving patients
world-class NHS care and he joins me now
from our westminster studio good morning
to you I know we're talking about your
the best part of a billion pounds of
investment in these services and we've
got to say while some people a lot of
people will say great it knows it's it's
really good that this investment is
going in the rest of the population may
say well why is it says in one of the
papers this morning we still having to
wait three weeks to see a GP well of
course we need investments across the
board the NHS and that's what we plan to
do today's news is of a billion pounds
of capital projects building projects
essentially and for more mental health
services also a new Children's Hospital
in Cambridge that will give cutting-edge
world-class care to two sick children
and also improvements a and E's around
the country because there's obviously
pressures on A&E z-- especially over the
winter now there's there's there's the
need to for more GPS that's less about
the capital improvement and then the
building's it's more about getting the
people and we've got a record number of
GPS in training so right across the
board we know that there's improvements
needed in the NHS and and we plan to
deliver on that we've got a long term
plan that we're currently writing with
the NHS leaders themselves but that's
that long-term plan is basis now it's
all funded that you've through the
budget but it's based on twenty point
five billion pounds extra going in every
year by 2020 324 that's based on not
paying to be in Europe well as things
currently stand and we'll there's a
possibility we may still be in the EU
isn't that well that money is is
guaranteed in all brexit scenarios it's
the decision of the of the government
that the NHS is our number one
spending priority I mean that's reflects
both the needs of the service and also
the wishes of most people now of course
the best way to both deliver on the vote
in the referendum and also to ensure
that our economy stays strong we stay
economically close to Europe is to
support the Prime Minister's deal and
there's one of the arguments I'm making
ahead of the vote on Tuesday is that
both No Deal scenario is has has
difficulties and won't be good for the
economy but also we've got to deliver on
the on the vote in the referendum and
therefore the best thing to do is to
vote for the Prime Minister's deal at
whilst we're still conflating the two
issues well everything was completed
with a brexit can I ask you about the
green paper on Social Care that was due
to be published before Christmas and
obviously Social Care is a hugely
important issue with everything that's
going on before brexit you're not
actually going to be able to get that
out are you
well that that works going on in fact
it's very it's very mature very well
advanced this green paper has been a
long time in the coming and I want to
make sure that the details are right and
that we get the and that when we publish
it it gets the attention and we can have
the debate that it deserves and as you
say there's an awful lot going on in
Parliament at the moment so there's a
bit of a pressure on on parliamentary
time so we'll see whether I we can get
it out as we said we would before the
end of the year or whether it needs to
slip into early January in a way what
matters most is that we have a long term
solution again to the social care
challenges these are challenges that
haven't grown up overnight this this has
been debated for 20 or 30 years how we
put social care on a sustainable footing
I'm confident that when the paper is
published it'll show that we can make
some some real progress towards that it
has to be done on a on a broad
consultative
broadly consensus basis because there's
these sorts of problems like with the
funding of
social care a bit like the funding of
pensions are best done when all parties
come together for an agreement and and
so that's that's the basis that we're
working on it in terms of Tuesday then
and the brexit vote is there any point I
mean in all honesty of planning ahead
knowing you're heading towards a massive
defeat rather than actually taking a
step back and seeing what what can be
changed or whether the committee
renegotiations gray and braid each other
nineteen twenty two so Grahame says you
know why plow ahead if you know you're
gonna be defeated well the Downing
Street have been very clear that they
are holding the vote on Tuesday we've
already started the debate that that
runs towards that and what I'd say is
that if you listen to that debate it's
increasingly clear that the best option
is to vote for the deal and that's I
think that's what should happen on
Tuesday I think everybody should vote
for the deal because it's in the
national interest it's the best way
forward yes well that's your opinion
from listening to the debate if you
actually clock up the figures of who
says what you know when people make
their voting intentions clear it's
actually stacking up against you isn't
it and was it isn't that what the Prime
Minister was told last night at the
meeting of Ministers that you attended I
didn't see the Prime Minister yesterday
so I don't know what meeting you're
talking about but what what I what I do
know is is what I think is the best way
forward through this through this great
debate you know there's not another
option that commands the majority of the
House of Commons and more importantly
there isn't another option that's better
you know the second referendum would be
divisive can you imagine given the
divisive Nassim around if we then went
back to people but it wouldn't be
decisive because we said that this
should be the only referendum and there
wouldn't be a second one and you know
people like me who voted remain I accept
the result
because in advance I said everybody
should accept the result of this
referendum and then
yeah the other alternative if the
Commons passes nothing will be to go out
with no deal at all and I think that is
extremely difficult and not good for the
economy and would have some very serious
repercussions and so we should vote for
the deal because that's the best thing
on the table yeah okay let's the problem
is with this and and it is hugely
confusing I mean you know that and
you're you're involved in the in the
discussions to this sort of enth degree
when it comes to all these sort of
things for most of us it's it's all a
huge confusing mess and what people want
to know is when it looks like when the
sums say the Prime Minister the
government is going to lose this on
Tuesday and lose it pretty substantially
maybe by up to 200 votes then people
want to know what's Plan B what what is
anyone gearing towards what will happen
next are we looking at that
renegotiating and we're looking at No
Deal are we looking at a general
election even which is being talked
about here what is the next step if this
doesn't go through on Tuesday well you
know a general election I think would be
terrible in this current circumstances
when we've got a we're leaving the
European Union at the end of March and
we need to deliver on on the commitment
in the referendum and so you asked me
about all the other options and I'll
tell you this from the bottom of my
heart this is the best option on the
table it's the right thing to do and so
III don't think that we should be
talking about Plan B we should be
persuading everybody with with all of
the powers of persuasion at our disposal
that this plan is the best thing to vote
for and to do because it then delivers
on brexit then we can get on with it and
all the things we're talking about in
there all the things we're talking a
Health Service and a lot of people
believe that which is fair enough but
the reality is it's gonna take a minor
miracle to get this through on Tuesday
so people therefore want to know what is
gonna happen well you're prejudging it
I'm not I want to get on with the
you'll land it and then we can get on
with all the brilliant things that this
country can do you know we were talking
about improving the health service we
can get on with that we can concentrate
on making sure whether we provide more
and better paid jobs we can get on with
all the housing reforms that we want so
people can afford a home in the way that
they need to and there's the cutting
edge research agenda we could be the
global leaders in in new research in
artificial intelligence in genomics and
this week we've passed a hundred
thousand genomes sequence and that's a
revolutionary technology there's amazing
things that are on the horizon that we
can grasp and what we need to do is back
the deal settle this brexit issue and
then get on with it